i um
got the show you know the first show
and they said well what kind of father
are you going to be and i said well i'm
going to be a father that
is not going to go easy on the kids
and i'm going to be wrong and i'm going
to be wrong loud
you know like uh
i said one time don't you have pictures
of our where do you have the baby
pictures of our kids i said i don't have
those in here those kids look like
martians
hello everyone hola
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
bespoke post partners with small
businesses and emerging brands to bring
you the most unique goods every month no
matter what you're into their box of
awesome has you covered and you can get
20 off your first monthly box when you
sign up for box of awesome.com
and enter the code omghi
at checkout listen i got that carry-on
that i got from these guys and it was
amazing made it easier for me to travel
and i would welcome a box of awesome any
month hey everybody this is producer
grant here just a reminder if you like
the show if you're enjoying the show
please like comment subscribe on any
platform you're checking it out on
whether that's on youtube whether that's
apple podcast spotify anything any
engagement that we have really really
helps we all serve the almighty
algorithm these days and any amount that
you sort of interact with the show in
any way just really helps us out helps
us get cooler guests for the show helps
raise the profile for the show helps
give us more content for you guys to
enjoy so thanks again for checking it
out and please enjoy the episode
so um
who what what young man do we have here
yeah joining us today on the podcast we
have comedian vince calderon yeah hey
it's so great to thank you for having me
here i really appreciate it yeah yeah so
so uh where are you in your in your
in your career yeah no i've been doing
santa for like a little uh around like
eight to nine years now and i'm in a
place right now where i'm going to uh
record my first ever stand-up album and
stand up special
and uh so i've been like working on on
developing my hour and everything and
i'm actually going to record it in may
yeah nice yeah all right look
[ __ ] the ghost of mr
you ever you know what that show is no i
haven't seen it
you know what it is no it's a dude that
mrs muir bought a house like a on the
edge of some island and it had a like a
you know lighthouse and she would see
the ghost saw the the ghost of the
captain so it was like the ghost and mrs
muir
i don't know why he just seemed like a
ghost [ __ ] walking in
what's that on your uh
chest right there your
[ __ ] uh it's just lunch number to go
dating vehicles on the side the date i
see a two two two three two two two
prostate
two two two two fingers in the front two
of the
three
three in the back
i just come back from getting a cat scan
that's where i was at
and what happened
well they said that i think dennis
miller had the best uh line about
catskills you know out here actors put
down a cat scan as work you know
as film
oh
cheers i hope i hope you're uh you know
we've got to wish each other the best
because one day they're going to be they
did they gave me a result right away
yeah they gave me a it's a new machine
it's a
it's a new machine the doctor says it's
great it works good
and is that what he said he said the
machine is great than that it works good
yeah except for it breaks down it's a
new invention and it breaks down all the
time
but
how do you know that it didn't break
down on yours no because
this the film got up to the doc doctor's
office was upstairs
they did it downstairs went upstairs
doctor says hey let's look at it
brings it up electronically on the
screen you want to know when you're not
in good condition when the guy's like
yeah man you know i'm a huge fan i mean
it's funny that you're in here i mean
it's just such an easy procedure
yeah what's my dude oh um
i'm gonna
somebody will be coming in
to talk to you like uh
because you know when they see something
oh yeah they're they're not really paid
to be dim you know like the other doctor
would say that's there's something
within the margins i don't like yeah you
got some [ __ ] cholo
you know that with the with the scrubs
like seven times too big oh
[Laughter]
you had some concern i don't know
anything he just kept saying
[Laughter]
so so gil is a huge fan of uh comedy
this is a young man right here but i
said like you know like
a little cartoon sketch that you might
yeah who do they say sherman no which is
the other one is it the uh alfred newman
that guy from tv or something i've
gotten that before yeah yeah but do you
think it's good to look like a cartoon i
think you know i think when your face
has
like my you know they draw me all the
time i mean yeah there you go i've seen
some [ __ ] bad have you seen some bad
drawings of yourself oh for sure like
you go like the boardwalk and they do
the caricatures and you're like it makes
you feel so insecure like
i paid twenty dollars to make you make
me feel bad about myself
it's not like they can even say like man
you know i don't have to do this dude
like that then i said that i laugh at
myself all the time
i'm a [ __ ] artist you know what
[ __ ] you see your [ __ ] nose
watch this
yeah yeah brian was uh one time brian
was at uh at disneyland and there was a
a woman that was holding a baby but the
baby's head was facing brian he was in
line
so the baby got up and then the baby was
like this and the baby says that guy's
got a nose like a witch
and you think about that for the rest of
the day like that's all you're going to
think about when you go home your car
ride and everything let's take a picture
he's like no
i'm good let's get a picture of
ourselves here all right
you know
yeah yeah so so uh uh do you have a name
for the how how would you name your
special like yeah no that's i i felt
like that was also like a really hard
part in the whole like creation process
i i i want to call it up and coming uh
you know because like a lot of people
when they they like they see a comic
they say like this person's up and
coming but that i think there's some
points to them any porno movies oh sure
yeah i think so
it's also in reference to the
neighborhood that i live in you know
because like right now it's going
through a lot of changes and it's being
gentrified and so i felt like there was
like a double entendre and like up and
coming as a stand-up and an
up-and-coming
as my neighborhood you know so um it's
about it's a stand-up comedy documentary
and special okay we're gonna come up
with our own versions of names i would
love that in this time that we're here
all right all right
uh um
did you did your neighborhood get
gentrified no
did they have did you does your does
your neighborhood have to have
stores around it or just the homes are
being lived in by other people
i think it's like a like a mix of like
you see like homes are changing like the
like the like certain architecture
you'll be like oh this is different than
what we're used to and also like certain
businesses like there's like a cheese
store nearby and like we never had like
like an artisanal cheese store before
residents moving out businesses coming
in mm-hmm
exactly and
because business is buying everything up
to change the face of the neighborhood
yeah and but that hasn't happened uh
where i grew up
so there
my daughter lives in the house that i
grew up in yeah
right now is that is that how it's going
to stay in the family yeah
if nobody will sell it
i don't think she'll sell it now i i
don't know i don't i really don't have
any attachment to the house anymore you
know you don't feel an attachment to the
house no not that growing up in there
there's a little boy you go over there
i i have more attachment to the street
where we drew the baseball diamond and
the dead end right here
to the house
that was you know there was at one time
there was i had six
six sisters
and they were
five five sisters still living there
when i what were the sleeping
arrangements
very tight i mean because it's not a big
house
bedroom track home three three bedroom
uh we were social climbers coming from
94th naval on over to pikavira then it
was just pico
and
so we went there too my adult two of the
older sisters they were already gone
so then that meant uh betsy sylvia
uh myself and then i had two younger
sisters you only in cindy
and then for the most of the time it
became
uh
four girls and myself was it fun
i didn't care i didn't think about it
you know that was family i didn't know
anything when you came home from school
did your mom have food food they're
waiting or did you know my mom was
working my mom was working my dad was
working
and so when it was myself and my younger
sister so i was the cook i was yeah i
took care of them did you did your
parents did you grow up with your mom
and dad i grew up with my grandparents
uh so they raised me my parents were
like kind of in and out because they
were like incarcerated pretty often my
parents like lived like this sort of
like gangster lifestyle and everything
so they were like out and about doing
that stuff were they in gangs
they were like in gangs and stuff like
that so i grew up in glasgow park over
in northeast los angeles sure yeah yeah
so um uh while they were out my
grandparents would take care of me they
were super overprotective like my
grandma didn't like me going out with
people that she didn't know right she'd
always watch like the spanish news and
that would just like give her like
perpetual fear all the time and it's
louder than regular news it's also
scarier than regular news it's like a
telenovela like all the time
you know
remember that remember there was a guy
protesting like health care on the
freeway yeah and he had his dog in the
car with him
and he was sitting in there and he had
gas he had a pickup truck he stopped
and
he was in the car and they were trying
to talk to him but he had gas in the car
dog in there and he was in there and
eventually the fumes
you know are so much that if you even
open the door or anything clicks or
anything sparks
boom it boom then the cat the helicopter
looked away i put it on channel 34 they
had oh yeah
like a cracker when he jumped he didn't
move you know you had like a cracker
just still he jumped out of the back
window like that and that [ __ ]
was in one piece like he was just took
off that guy was in there and they
showed everything they don't hold back
at all
they don't know i think they're they
understand
that's what the people want to see yeah
exactly they don't give a [ __ ] about
your feelings this is what they want to
see were you ever in the car is that
where your comedy comes from like you
ever in the car when you're when your
mom and dad were in there like
yeah i was in the car when like my mom
and dad would get like into street
fights and stuff like that like at gas
stations like at restaurants and stuff
like that so like there was once a
street fight at a gas station my mom was
fighting this woman on thanksgiving and
while she was fighting
yeah whatever they just went to go get
gas on thanksgiving yeah i don't know we
weren't going anywhere but we have the
urge to go get gas in the morning yes
here's the stuffing
stuff
so she's fighting uh this woman at the
gas station right and there's no one to
watch how did it start like they were
putting gas like hey what the [ __ ] you
looking for is this woman that she just
had beef with like in the neighborhood
like you have like a first jewelry yeah
they knew each other and so she's going
to fight them but she's realizing oh my
kid's in the car so she asked the gas
station attendant to watch me while she
fought and this dude comes over he's
just watching me and then i can just
hear my mom yelling out like every
expletive i could think of and he's like
so how's school been and i'm like
beat up a woman right now [ __ ] yeah your
mom could throw hands she could throw
hands dude she was like also like a very
arrogant fighter like i swear whenever
my mom would beat someone up because we
lived in such a small neighborhood she
would drive to that person's house the
next day and as loud as possible she
would play the song move [ __ ] get out
the way
yeah and i know that cause like i was
the person to give her the cd to play it
you know i'd always be late to school
and everything so she had she do she
thought she
had a soundtrack yeah yeah
boxer's now coming out with your
soundtrack
i'm almost afraid to ask where's your
mom that now uh my mom my mom's around
uh she was like gone for a little bit
but i'm happy to have her back in my
life yeah good good and like i've been
trying to reconnect with my family with
my parents especially because i felt
like there was so much like missing time
in between and i feel like i'm taking my
parents on field trips and stuff like
that like things that we were never
really able to do yeah like i took my
parents like the aquarium of the pacific
and they tripped out i'm seeing all the
fish
they're like because they've never seen
that [ __ ] yeah they well our like
neighborhood i went to the same uh
elementary school middle school
everything is them and they we didn't
have a lot of good field trips so i'm
trying to take them on those good field
trips
and i'm like yeah there's like 27 000
species of fish and my dad's like man
trip out he's just like staring down all
the fish and stuff that fish
the little one looks like a bad fish
yeah i'm just hearing him say trip out
like 30 times on like the day yeah yeah
they would say tripod trip out
bad that's pretty that's pretty that's
that's cool yeah yeah so i'm happy to be
able to do that right now in my life
when you guys were estranged was it
because of the lifestyle or she was she
was away or uh she was away for a little
bit and then like just just different
parts you know like they're in and out
of jail a lot i'm the oldest of four so
i had to like really come into a
position where i had to take care of my
siblings right so um
i wouldn't have been good at that
because i'm an only child
two different colored socks
with a hole in them
that no kids would
would go to school like i'm not going to
i have two different socks you're going
to school with [ __ ] three different
socks
my sister still tells me today she hated
because i took care of my two younger
sisters
and she says i can still remember today
you making us eat raw pancakes
eat them that's the way they're supposed
to be
yeah that's how i make them yeah yeah
exactly yeah
that's cool man and uh
how did um i mean it's interesting man
how how people find you know find comedy
yeah like what were you into did you
draw or did you like music or did you
try to play instrument in school or your
friends or what what it's so funny
because like i i feel like i didn't
really grow up in a household that was
expressive of ideas you know it was no
one like that could ever be like oh yeah
go go paint or go do this and you can
end up somewhere like a museum or
whatever right um when my parents were
away my grandparents would take care of
me and like late at night i'd watch tv
because they'd fall asleep like crazy or
like seven right
and so i'd watch like the channels that
would turn into like a completely
different network at nighttime and so i
saw comedy central and i saw my first
comedian and i was like oh people can
just talk and people will laugh at that
and the first comic i saw was maria
bamford and that became like my first
comedian like my favorite comic to watch
and then i start watching it more like
in secrecy my grandparents didn't know
what the [ __ ] was happening they were
talking about this thought it was like
an infomercial or something right right
right uh and then from there i would
just like kind of keep on watching it
while they'd fall asleep
yeah grandpa when your grandparents
raise you
my grandparents used to watch luke chad
leave it you know
they used you know they they watched
wrestling they thought it was real and
they would get mad mr moto the destroyer
they thought it was real
and they'd get pissed off at the ship so
my grandmother told me that
the pantera negra the black panther yeah
was her brother i don't know
and that he lost one time and she jumped
in the ring
and hit somebody with her with her shoe
because they were choking them and i
don't know
you don't know if that shit's true
i mean yeah and they had a picture of
them you know with the black and white
with the shorts and you know yeah like
that but i i don't i mean
both my grandparents loved wrestling
and they get mad they believed it was
true but they were divorced you know
they didn't live with each other they
hated each other
as a matter of fact when i was in the
army my mom told me one time she's
crying on the phone i said what's wrong
she says i found out i was a bastard my
grandma my grandpa never got married
they just lived with it and then i found
out that my grandfather had kids all
over the southwest he was a traveling
man i had different families yeah
yeah you know i couldn't have had
another family he was i
he was uh i found out very proud he was
a vista he came to the us running from
the federales
through chihuahua
into uh new mexico
went through texas in new mexico that's
where he settled and we just had my mom
everywhere everywhere he put his hat
there that's right everybody took his
hat off and followed everywhere he put
his hat was his home [ __ ] getting it
oh you see his hat on the wall let's not
go his hats off
that's the sock on the door you know
if you see my [ __ ] hat on that chair
you better not come in here
what kind of stuff did your family like
to watch when you were growing up
you know my grandmother was a racist so
uh-huh we watched lawrence welcome when
arthur duncan went down she would go
they that's not george they
not him i'm like yeah
any any you know they're very musical
was another one that she would say
they're very musical
i mean you know i just think that
everybody was
i mean
war is at some point but but
they watched
they watched um i didn't watch
my grandmother
i i don't remember where i started it
sounds like my mom
i don't remember her watching tv she was
always busy
either cooking for my dad doing stuff
for the house yeah she worked during the
day and my dad was a hard worker
my dad used to he watched lawrence walk
that was one of his uh i always wanted
to go to they go where is that every
week
where is that george the [ __ ] hollywood
palladium next week same thing hollywood
palladium
boxing
yeah as well what did they watch uh
novellas yeah my mom didn't watch a
novella you know
and my dad didn't have that much time
hard working man labor you know he'd
come home
uh drink beer
smoke a cigarette go to bed you know
you may watch a game or two in between
that no he wasn't he was an avid dodger
fan yeah yeah one television in the
house
uh he was there i remember when on tv
wasn't working during the day and then
it you could see like arthur
yeah and then a
comedy special and then at night it
would go after dark stuff you know so i
was i was always a light sleeper like i
would get up
you know just and and and i saw the tv
on under the door and i was like did i
leave the tv on yeah
and i went over there and i looked and
my grandfather's standing in front of
the tv but it's on tv and you can see
like half a naked person
yeah
like a like a tit and then it would wave
and then maybe it was clear and then i
went like that and he had a
[ __ ] rod
and i was like
i just like backed up like oh i
mirror yeah through the blue of the tv
no that was nasty i don't think i've
ever told anybody that cause it's just a
little hallway and i went like that i
was like oh [ __ ]
my grandparents used to watch like el
chavo de locho um
my grandmother would watch horror movies
all the time but she didn't have them
dubbed so she'd watch the american
version of it and she would tell me what
she thought the movie was about
you know so like michael myers would be
out and chasing people and she'd like
that's what happens when you don't do
your homework right
i'm like oh man this is just a series
about a guy trying to get kids to learn
better you know
i was watching cycle during the day on
channel 11
and my and you know i was
you know when you would stand in front
of the tv and just watch you know
well it came about the [ __ ]
like all the blood goes down to your
feet
[Laughter]
but there's just not that many people in
the house yeah so when you would be
concentrating or they would tell me uh
that's they'd go hey hey and they were
going like this and i go what we're
talking to you and i
couldn't you'd be right there and i
didn't yeah i didn't hear because you're
so into what you're watching
yeah
which is i think why that i have
incredible recall for [ __ ] that doesn't
make any sense of no value like if my
mind was a garage you would go and open
the door and you'd be like why do i have
this [ __ ] in here i just told somebody
about a pet rock and the rubik's cube
and and all this party town and all the
things you could get skunk perfume
and gum that tastes like pepper they
would spit it i mean [ __ ] that you're
like why am i what am i talking about
why is this in my brain yeah there used
to be a party town
store like a novelty store
in every did you guys have one in your
town uh the the novelty stuff probably
the starbucks right now yeah it's
probably starbucks now uh but the ice
cream trucks would always sell like the
stuff that was like novelty you know
like the gum or like smoke bombs and
like all that sort of stuff things that
they shouldn't be selling but they have
it in the ice cream truck i think the
ice cream was banging my mom to it
[Laughter]
where in the [ __ ] does that mean you
know why because my mom used to call the
guy joe oh joe's coming how the [ __ ] you
don't [ __ ]
man
it was always ice cream man nobody said
oh here comes joe
i didn't see if he put a little [ __ ]
popsicle by the door to let me know that
he was right there
he didn't wear a hat
i should get those they used to sell us
plaques that had like a guy screaming
and would say don't
stop talking when a
guy screaming and it would say like stop
dinner
[ __ ] stop talking when i'm interrupting
or something else oh yeah something like
a joke cute little thing that yeah you
know got him you show it to your brother
what the [ __ ] is this that was a big
deal
i mean that's all gone like ice cream
man yeah all he had then was a good
humor guy he would come and holly sold
his ice cream did you ever did you ever
helms truck donuts that's what i was
gonna say did you ever see a helmet's
bakery truck i've never seen a helmet
i don't even think i know what that like
did they just sell like when i die i
want to be i want to be buried i want
one to take me to the sombrero mission
cemetery it was just uh it was just a
like a little it was a fashion van going
over there over there in culver city by
m by sony there was the bakery and now
it's like a art place you can go in
there and live in space is [ __ ] yeah
yeah but they had a medallion
they were helm's bakery
and it looked like a panel like a chevy
panel thing
and the the horn would be like
right there right there
oh dude that looks so cool very
throwback and it was the guy would open
it up and they had like pies and cakes
and then you would say what kind of
doughnuts do you have and this
[ __ ] would pull a drawer out
that was longer than you're like how the
[ __ ] is stronger than the car yeah but
he'd pull it out dude and there would be
like fresh like
powdered donuts glaze muffins cakes
chocolate doughnuts replaced everything
on this thing man
i i can still remember our gl our helm
man his name was dick
and he
there was a lady
but there was a lady that lived in the
cold side she was so sexy that's the
first time i saw a lady in a bra i saw
in the window
she she was going out there with a bra
no no i'd see you through the window you
know light on the inside dark on the
outside i wouldn't be tom but just
walking right
and you could see it
well she would sway and she'd go up
there and dick was out there was it i
was a kid but i'm saying oh
he's doing more than selling donuts at
that place he was going in there oh
it was a
it was nice and was his name joey just
don't hurt my feelings
i don't want to mention her name because
she still has family but you know what
that that over the back of it i mean
listen matt i mean look at that [ __ ] man
like i would be so happy to see that if
oh
i mean i'd love if we still and we had a
helms bakery right there i lived in pico
in montebello just a few miles away we
had a helms bakery there you know so you
know we get away from the things that
like
you know we're much older than you but
then you
have to see those things i think in your
life in order to i mean some committees
don't
talk about where they came from i think
you do right yeah i talk about where i
came from and my whole like living
situation but to have a dad that was a
banger a mom that was a
banger that's yeah and and and i mean
you're
very you know you
um but yeah i mean like the whole whole
thing was like interesting because like
you know they they were in that realm
and stuff and i feel like part of like
what i was trying to do with the special
just kind of illustrate that just
because someone comes from that sort of
background doesn't mean that they're
like a terrible person either because
like a lot of the gangsters in my
neighborhood are disappearing and i
don't like that because they always made
me feel safe right like i always felt
like they created some kind of community
and people just kind of like vilify that
sometimes where the [ __ ] do they go yeah
yeah no
and my parents were never like that you
know my parents were always good law
abiding i was more afraid of my dad than
i was of the cops yeah at that time my
dad was a
she was straight but those are those are
dudes like that weren't afraid of the
police right yeah there was a guy named
frank over there in pacoima
come negrito he was always in a t-shirt
long shorts and those slippers the
corduroy slippers or white socks
and then they would go
the police would go to his house and
they'd walk in there and he would walk
them out to their car
and they would say all right we'll see
you and he's like all right yeah it's
hot i got grass for which i was just
like [ __ ] those guys
like and you're just like man how could
they do it openly he'd be so cool to
walk cops out to the car and they'd come
and say listen dude you know
if you know anything about this we know
you're not going to tell us but can you
tell them to stop
which is pretty much
they came for respect to say
you know this is showing up on our radar
kind of keep it
you know let's keep it contained or
whatever i don't know what they said but
he wasn't afraid to see a dude that's
not afraid of cops
when you're a little kid that that
[ __ ] becomes like a hero right
like wow this is crazy
was uh that lapd or san fernando
that was ali that was foothill foothill
you know we're crazy that's why
i didn't do that with a shirt you know
be real said
they didn't treat
they didn't know they didn't did you
know that the sheriffs were
tougher than lapd i didn't know that
well i i didn't know either i thought
the lapd i thought the sheriffs were
he's like oh no the sheriff's you didn't
[ __ ] with you didn't lie to him they'd
[ __ ] you up yeah and lapid you could
tell them anything they'd go away
absolutely i think i learned recently
that the whole like calling 9-1-1 didn't
start into like the 80s or something
where you could like dial that yeah it
started in los angeles yeah no way yeah
i had no idea so you want a job when it
started yeah
before they were just dial zero yeah
what'd you do before they dialed either
zero and the operator would switch you
over give you enough or you just call
the station they had that station number
then when i was already selling it
started 9-1-1 and when the 9-1-1 call
came in
the call automatically gave you an
address except for cell phones i don't
know how cell phones work now cell
phones used to go to highway patrol but
i don't know how they work today
so um i know because that's all of a
sudden now they don't come anymore
but if you call 9-1-1 they don't show up
really i mean there's way more people
that's there
so if you say prowler they're like
prowler you live in the lapd's area
yeah i think i do [ __ ] yeah
those [ __ ] told me not to call
them if i ever have a situation so i
guess i'm on my own
it's like the citizen app and stuff like
that now where like people kind of
report crime on their own and you can
kind of see what's going on in your
community you know they used to call it
vigilante but then they had to change
the name because they didn't want it
like oh perpetuate like that and you
know let me go back those officers said
that if i ever have a situation not for
me not to call them
i i use the profanity when expressing
officers i meant when these officers
came to my house they said
because of my stance in comedy which is
comedy and not real life exactly when
does when does a comedian's words
make the secret service come to your
house but a [ __ ] politician's words
mean nothing
to to [ __ ] demonize people to vilify
what the [ __ ] is here
to the [ __ ]
let me say officially i'm fighting the
fight on your behalf because i do have
friends who say is he still anti i said
hey he's a comedian
that's not the way he lives that's not
the way he's a great guy he thought i
was anti-police yeah huh
i said
no
hey if you want to make fools of
yourself and get in trouble you know
you're easy you're an easy target fair
cop well you know i talk about everybody
i think sure i think a comedian [ __ ] you
talk about me
i said that he could catch a
nightstalker but can't control his blood
pressure
[Laughter]
this winter upgrade your daily routine
with bespoke post and their new seasonal
lineup of must-have box of awesome
collections bespoke post partners with
small businesses and emerging grants to
bring you the most unique goods every
month now here's one of those things
that you know at the house i didn't
notice that
my knives were missing like you know you
know one was gone and the longer one's
gone but box have also uh replaced the
knives that were missing with
better knives that i had so you know if
you get into the box of awesome you look
forward to getting a new box of awesome
every month every month you look forward
to getting a new box of awesome
every month
grant and it goes beyond that no matter
what you're into they've got something
for you box of awesome winter cocktails
cozy threads camping gear essentials
like you said they've got knives of
every sort they've even got like a
machete thing that i think we have here
um all sorts of great stuff from box of
awesome you know yeah that stuff is
pretty good man because you know it's
the stuff that you wouldn't think to get
for yourself but you need it it's on the
peripheral of stuff that
is important to you and then when you
like when i got the knives i was like oh
man that's exactly what i need and then
when i got the carry-on for the luggage
and i always you know accumulate more
stuff coming back it was able to handle
some of the stuff from my suitcase it
made it easier for me to travel i
actually had the weekender bag i was
going through the airport and someone
literally stopped me they're like i
never do this where did you get that bag
there you go so to get started just take
the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month across tons of
categories it's free to sign up you can
skip a month or cancel anytime to get
started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
now that's that's that's what we're
talking about now and they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories and it's free to
sign up and you can skip a month or
cancel any time and each box is valid
around 70 but you only pay a fraction of
that price it's almost like when they
would have those
they say white elephant sales was just
like everything that people
needed yeah didn't want that someone
else needed yeah
listen
there's this will you know i used to go
to the salvation army there was a place
in in pacoima there lake view terrace
that was almost like sanford and son
like you walk in there and they had
everything in there and it was packed in
those aisles you know they go you want
that bike you need to spend 40 minutes
digging furniture out to get it from
around you just see the end of the
handlebar but it's funny when i think
about box of awesome and then you think
about
going into one of those places and how
excited i was because you never knew
where you were going to get and i think
that's what box of awesome is now
without you know the ride to lakeview
terrace it comes to your house you open
the box
and there you go
there you go get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter the code omghi
at checkout that's box of awesome.com
code omghi for 20 off your first box box
of awesome.com code omg hi
have you ever gotten in a fist fight oh
dude i've never been in a fist fight in
my life and i'm so thankful for it i
don't know how i would do i don't know
if i'd be like fight or flight on it but
i i hope like there's always you might
be one of those crazy [ __ ]
i'm hoping like that gangster gene is
somewhere in my body and it'll just like
be activated when i need it to happen
you know almost like a superhero like
yeah when the [ __ ] comes down you know
all of a sudden the grad you graduate
sure you look at your fists and it's
getting ten times bigger
because the head's breaking out you know
yeah like like uh fantastic four yeah
but but uh they did your parents uh did
they hit you growing up no ah they
didn't fall they didn't hit me because
they were in jail so they weren't able
to hit me as a kid did you go see them
in jail through the glass and all that
yeah i do all that you know i'd go to a
place and i'd have to get on the bus and
then it take me like another part of it
and then i you know wait like two or
three hours sometimes that's a county
then they go up the wayside so they do a
wayside uh is it where they were were
they in the wayside i don't remember the
exact prison and stuff like that but
like i remember the snacks and the
vending machines and stuff
it's like there's certain things that
like give me good memories like keebler
fudge stripe cookies i love those but i
would only eat them when i would go
visit my parents because they'd be in
the vending machine
it's trip man to have your parents be in
in prison well they did i i don't know
if he understands the difference between
prison in a county jail you know like a
wayside yeah you know no but they were
in prison right they'd be in prison uh
sometimes they'd go to jail depending on
what they did so they'd be um they'd
have like longer terms where they would
be in prison and then uh jail would be
like maybe two years i think where
they'd be like away do people do real
hard time in county jail
can you do more than can you do more
than
once you're sentenced you can only be
sentenced to a maximum a year in county
jail but you could be in county jail for
two three years pending trial
it's only after conviction then your
time served and if you're sentenced to a
misdemeanor you stay in county jail if
you're sentenced to a felony then they
transfer you you know one of my first
jokes was in high school that my dick
would get harder than a year in county
jail
[Laughter]
it would kill him on a baseball team
yeah do you do you set up like old like
notebooks and stuff like that from when
you like started out in your your career
and everything yeah
you know
when uh when
i mean i would write it's funny man i
would write notes to myself yeah
about things that i wanted to do
and you know i'm an only child i would
write them or i would go to the
to the market with my grandmother
safeway or thrifty mart or thrifty's and
get
those notepads uh
that were like this size and you'd have
like a green from the right and i still
have some of those yeah wow some of
those
but you don't know what's gonna you
don't know what's gonna happen yeah it's
really cool to like reflect on those two
to be like oh i can't believe like this
is some of the stuff that i used to
think of when writing a joke and stuff
like that you know and sometimes you'll
be like maybe i should try that one now
and see if it works you know yeah
in uh
where are you gonna where are you gonna
shoot your your special i'm gonna shoot
it at the bob baker marionette theater
oh yeah where is that uh in highland
park it's like on york boulevard uh may
10th of may 12th oh [ __ ] man bob baker
remember about baker marianne i remember
the marionettes
being able to put that [ __ ] on that
screen right there i remember bob baker
marionettes there was a friend of mine
that actually bought the place for a
while oh really yeah and he was running
for a while
is it that one and
he was he was into everything though how
big is that place it's pretty big i mean
eddie maldonado yeah fast that he had
best eddie and he got a
plaque from the city for dooney
and his son's still around man yeah no
that's so i mean i love that place so
much
uh on in highland park uh near york uh
york boulevard is it in a cul-de-sac uh
no uh it's like on one of like the
popular it's like on the someone like
one of the gentrified streets now but um
i wanted to shoot it there because i'm
kind of jealous of that place because i
never had a place like that in my own
neighborhood so i felt like this is the
place where i'd like for this to happen
they do comedy there they do they don't
do comedy they actually only do puppet
shows and they do like private events
which is like what you know um if you're
able to get one how big is that
67 to 100 seats just south of the
occidental college yeah
no that's pretty cool
man bob baker mary you don't remember
bob baker i don't remember him but i
remember the marionettes
that that i do because i didn't i was a
kid that was
hey
with the little white glass and we would
be like shh
how did that and then you buy the ones
in tijuana when you came across them
i was able to take it tour that place
too and the entire second floor is just
like an archive of like books and
records and all these sort of things
that like inspire the creation of that
theater and all the puppets some of
those puppets are actually um from like
disneyland like he would make puppets
for disneyland and you know like those
little like window displays where like
they'd be moving and animated he helped
make some of those for disney
um yeah it's a lot of impressive like i
geek out whenever i'm there i just love
being like did you see the original ones
yeah yeah you see some of the original
stuff there too remember wayland flowers
and madam yes yes i've searched
[Laughter]
you know how like you know that's how
that's how kind of uh
i'm not saying that we weren't the
sharpest knives in there that somebody
like peter allen or you know i know
elton john you know uh that that were
flamboyant
were show men and they weren't nobody
thought they were gay they thought they
were human yeah like even i would be
like they go you know uh paul lin is
liverachi libarachi he said you know
what man just because likes to put on a
good show yeah he has to love men
you know
little did i know that you know yeah
those guys would call me
behind the candelabra was
earth-shattering to me
you know what's behind the cannonballs a
big hard [ __ ] fear
[Laughter]
coming out of a [ __ ] jacuzzi full of
suits
i got it i don't know i mean you know
i don't know how you i don't know how
you do this uh big shot
your show this last weekend at microsoft
was the best and and i've told i've paid
good money to go see this man before i
ever met him
and
i laughed hard it was the best thing
i've ever seen best stand-up i've ever
seen it was and the stuff you thought
would still be i'm trying to tell my
wife yeah we said this and i'm laughing
and but it doesn't come off
like it does with you yeah and half the
[ __ ] she doesn't
what about a chase a dog that was
barking at me
dude the dog barks at her would run away
and i said i chased that [ __ ]
that grew up without a father
[ __ ] come back
you're just like you just had it
she she got she got upset with me
a word she hates
kaka
she hates the word guys and at one point
in this show he talks about people take
pictures of their phone and they send
somebody and he hears they take a
picture of a caca here before and after
before after that's a dick for dessert
yeah
[Laughter]
um
did you take somebody with you the first
time where'd your first time you go on
stage the first time i went on stage was
actually uh a
nervous coffee shop in highland park uh
and i was very nervous dude i mean
what's
it is it's nerve hey you know what you
love comedy you should try to go doing
it yeah
let me tell you something man isn't it
isn't it frightening it is frightening
because you're it's like a weird mix for
like you're very excited but also so
nervous to share the ideas because
you're like do i think other people are
going to think that this idea i have is
funny and that's the the scary part you
know because if it's not then you're
like you're going to feel how long those
three minutes or however long you end up
doing but also if you do it and you you
you're not getting any laughs yeah which
which is rare even that to do it and get
laughs but also if you
do i mean how many times can somebody
go and take a beating before you say
like maybe this isn't for me exactly
yeah but then you quit
for good like i stopped and started a
lot but
i
i would always stop so you know to go
and
get a couple of laughs and then you're
it's scary as [ __ ] to get up there and
your whole day is thinking about that
[ __ ] you look at the clock you go i
got a lot of seven o'clock it's two
right now then it's four
and then it's like 5 15 and then you're
just like
then you go over there they call your
name and you gotta yeah [ __ ] step up
on the thing
and they don't know you either so yeah
so it's like also like they're
introducing this person and you want to
like kind of give a good impression you
know i feel like there's been so many
moments for like i go to a new place and
then they say my name and i'm like
nobody here knows me what if i just
walked away and they're like oh i guess
they're not here you know
because it is scary i will admit that
it's like did you ever do that did you
ever walk away no no i was like i'm here
i'm here because i want to try this and
i need to get this just so i can have
that closure of like this is what would
have happened and this is what did
happen you know
[ __ ] i've been
asked that hey you could do this but you
got to do almost already in those in
your speeches yeah yeah you know i i use
humor as a vehicle to get my point
across it's helpful and i do a lot of
lectures so i i do that and i've been
around it and i've been asked not
to go ahead and
why don't you do this guilty
and i couldn't do it as regular living
as a continuum one night he said gil
my comedian's late he's not here oh he
says go on up there you could do give me
10 minutes you could do this i know you
can yeah and i said no you guys do it
for a living no thank you
i wouldn't mind trying it was fun being
up with momo
you know
up there and doing some stuff with him
i could stand up there you could say
like this i like being around mom
because it makes me feel thin
like that's a good one to start with
in the old johnny oda show i was with
him and have to have a [ __ ] is like the
three tons of joy
the [ __ ] hefty man those dudes
you know i told momo you don't really
have to book every comedian that's
that's almost like those russian nesting
dolls
yeah
that's what you can go up there and say
it looks like those russian nesting
dolls like i go momo goes inside of me
and then i go inside hampton
i could do it for a few minutes but not
if i knew i had a show coming up
you know if it was something like hey
you were up there with it and and do it
maybe but i i don't know that i could do
what about when there's nothing up there
like
saturday there's 7 100 people up there
there's nothing up there but a stool no
water yeah yeah i mean that big-ass
stage where
[ __ ] bands play i'm just up there by
myself
it wouldn't bother me the the number of
people doesn't bother me at all because
i've spoken in front of you know
7 000 people before that that the
numbers don't bother me
it's just
you got to make them entertain you know
you're proud you got to make them laugh
if that's what you're doing better say
something's going to make them laugh and
if they're not laughing
i'd be able to walk off the [ __ ]
stage man i've heard like people say
like you know the audience gives you
their time you give them a memory you
know kind of being cognizant of all the
things that they're also putting on the
line
you've heard me laugh before yeah
there was a comedian up there that was
doing a show and and
the emcee was no good he was no good
started off
and it was a fundraising but they had
kids there and kid it was like a mexican
wedding kids running around sliding on
the floor
and this guy went up there and okay now
we have a comedian for you and here he
is and he went up there and he was a
friend of mine
and he went up there and he started
doing his stuff and he was [ __ ] dying
oh
nobody was laughing more who was it
gilbert
no rudy wouldn't know it was rudy he was
dying but dying for real or dying
because he's
because he comes up no he was annoyed he
was
the crowd was dead they weren't live
they weren't paying attention and i'm
laughing my ass off and he knew
i was laughing not because his [ __ ] was
that funny but because he was dying he
was going down
he would tell joe he'd say something
funny and nobody would laugh and i'd go
ah
and and when he got off he said cabron i
knew what the [ __ ] you were doing you
were laughing because i was dying
once in a while you got to take an ass
kick in though yeah and and he and it
wasn't his fault
if the emcee would have given him a
better enter would have gotten the crowd
it has a lot i think that has a lot to
do with the two right sure you're
sending the vibe you like better set the
crowd up and and this guy
was a tv personality but he wasn't a
good emcee like that
and so too bad do you still get nervous
at all when you go up and do your shows
or is that like
no not really yeah you know you you know
i was never a uh
a comedian that would do it by the
numbers you know yeah and i've tried
but
i've gotten it pretty pretty close to
because i used to do those specials live
yeah and you have to be a little bit
by note you know yeah but saturday
wasn't
uh that i thought about it during the
day and i thought you know then you got
to go against your instinct but you know
all that it's almost like what did they
say when i when i they gave me the jazz
festival that all the musicians they
were like oh yeah we know why they
picked you because when you
do it you just like find things you know
and like jazz like you know the notes
you play the notes an hour all right
i'll play the notes for an hour and you
know that but trying to get somebody
who's
a
reader of music
to be a jazz player jazz little ball
improvisation and just being in the
moment yeah and and the other stuff is
like you know you know like watching now
whiplash i like whiplash that movie
because you know they're trying to go by
the notes and stuff but that guy you
know
and then so to me there's two different
two different kinds i don't think they
make
i found out the hard way as a musician i
could read
but yeah your music i couldn't uh
improvise like do you go do you go
is it a script or do you go how do you
go um i i try to like pick like the the
beats and stuff like finding like a
rhythm where um i feel like everything
is connected by like one through line
and that makes it kind of easier for me
to be like well instead of like what's
the next joke it's like when i end here
this is the next thing i'm going to talk
about and how it relates to the last
thing i just talked about because i i
feel like i'm nervous of like having to
like jump from one topic to the other in
a way that doesn't feel organic so i
like in having it in that sort of way
it's been really helpful in doing my
stand up you know have your parents say
you do stand up yeah they have
at first like what did you hear from the
back tripod
um the first
time
up there
that's funny dick yeah yeah and stuff
like that um they saw me to stand up
when i was like 19 and um it was a show
where that al madrigal hosted so it was
him uh melissa via senor jesus trejo
chris garcia and myself and that was the
first time they saw me do stand up and
they liked it and they were supportive
and that meant a lot to me you know
because like a few years i told my mom
before it before i did that i wanted to
stand up she's like wow you're not funny
and i was like all right cool
i think that's what i say anyways yeah
but that's also like kind of like in a
weird way i feel like it's kind of
loving or it's like show me or like
prove me wrong you know and i felt like
in that instance like i felt like i
proved to them like this is something i
can do you know
when i when i um
got the show you know the first show
and they said well what kind of father
are you going to be and i said well i'm
going to be a father that is not going
to go easy on the kids
and i'm going to be wrong and i'm going
to be wrong loud
you know like
i said one time don't you have pictures
of our where do you have the baby
pictures of our kids i said i don't have
those in here those kids look like
martians
you know like so i would say uh
one time the kid would have the whole
computer out of there
and i said i walked around the corner
just added what are the bill gates
jingles man he goes don't you have the
protection plans have you had a
protection plan you both of you wouldn't
be here you're like that
they're like
the scripts we write it's like where is
that
but but i learned that in in that
body of that show that the way that i
was going to make it work was not to be
a comedian that i saw who had a show and
i went to go see him i was at the improv
and he was on and i was i think i was
i didn't go never went down there to
look but he was very safe
and he wasn't safe before he got the
show and i saw him outside
i said what are you working on he goes
awesome stuff you know because my show
is you know a family show and i don't
want people to see my tv show and then
come and see me and then i'm
different and i said and when he i
remember him driving away i was like
[ __ ] matt and i don't think did i have
my show yet maybe not but i thought if i
get a show i'm not gonna
go
easy so that people think they're coming
to see the guy from tv that's the kiss
of death like you know the stand-up
would be the main engine and
everything's come off of the main engine
you know so
um i didn't do that and then
a lot of early on kids would come and
see me and i remember i was in [ __ ]
lake tahoe and i walked out there and
there was a little two [ __ ] kids
sitting next to each other with a hat
[ __ ] burger king [ __ ] crown
and it was sold out i'm like what the
[ __ ] are these kids so you're trying to
adjust
and it's tough to adjust yeah and
then we decided started to put down that
you had to be over 18 or 21 because it's
just easier for me yeah but then you
know these girls i remember these little
girls in at the dodge theater in arizona
they were like eight years old they sent
me these notes and they're like i love
you so much george lopez i watch your
show when i grew up on marry you and i
was like i was like okay
go over there and bring these girls over
here and bring their parents over here
and they went backstage and told their
parents this is not a show that they
would enjoy that you would enjoy them
seeing yeah so i took pictures with the
little girls and then i took pictures of
the family i gave them their money back
i told him to trust me that
you know this was probably don't tell
him just probably the easier for all of
us good and then that's great i saw
those notes and i told my dude throw
these [ __ ] notes away because if some
police officers
that i'm dating a nine-year-old she
can't wait to marry me
like
let me see burn them up man like i don't
want to see that [ __ ] good for you yeah
that's savvy on two levels right and
that was tough that was tough to do i
think it's really cool though to have
like that self-awareness of like you
know i don't want someone to come in and
think that it's going to be a certain
thing you know um it's also like amazing
to see like what you mean to so many
people in that regard too like i mean it
must feel nice to see those notes did
you see that fool on the street uh
protesting me at the microsoft there's
one dude someone protested listen man i
pissed off thousands of people yeah but
when you can piss one dude off
you're so specific that you're surprised
somebody didn't kick his ass out he was
out there with a megaphone
i thought those all went away
but you know you still you know you
don't take it personal well there was a
difference and one reason i never went
to see him
your friend bob saget yeah he did he had
this persona from television yeah and i
understand his stand-up was
different 180 degrees man from what he
did on tv if i'd have known that [ __ ]
i'd have been at every show i know man
yeah i think it's interesting that with
those
with those i don't know so much man like
like cat williams i saw on damon wayne's
show and i thought he was hilarious and
when you go see him he's hilarious but
then you know you go off the deep end
and and however you know
i never wanted i've gone off the deep
end but not not not like that no not not
to
to ruin a tour or tours of people
but just anything it just
it was good you know
there was a there was a good blend
yeah of everything in your show not just
the dark side you know so it was good it
was when i got divorced i said i was i
was pretty dark oh yeah it was i had
some fans send me letters saying hey man
i don't know what you're going through
but
you know
i'm telling you it's the best show
bar none
saturday that was the best thing you
know the big you know the biggest thing
is that
mine and my ex-wife went to the show and
then ryan said to me in a message i'm
here with with mommy you know let me
know and i'll come in there by myself
but i let them both in there yeah
you took pictures of us together and
uh
i met her for the first time i would say
that
i don't know why
i don't know why i was mad at her for
getting divorced [ __ ] i'm the one that
caused it but i don't know why i was mad
i think it's just part of of i think
your dad asked your dad yeah yeah
he was probably tripping out
but but i mean you know that
i don't know it's just that what we're
built into
i knew i knew it was me but i was still
mad
and and as loud as i laughed there was
some guy behind me that was laughing his
ass off just as much as i was well at
least there's two of us ha
nuts in here watching yeah yeah and it
turned and it turned out it was big boy
he was big boy
he loves that [ __ ] oh
god that's awesome and i didn't find out
until we were talking later he says that
was you right in front of me then
because he heard me say that i was
sitting by maya
it's pretty good man because you know
that's
7100 people going at the same time all
yeah all going at the same time oh
have you uh have you acted at all have
you ever opportunity to act um i i've
been like on auditions and stuff like
that but i haven't like had the
opportunity to go like to a bunch of
like different people have you taken
acting class i actually i feel like i
really need to but i would like to like
pursue that to some degree like i like
writing like sketch writing and like
stand-up comedy but i do know that like
i should maybe try to
explore the other world of that you know
you know i want to tell you that i think
it's critically important yeah because
um
just even even in this latest uh show
that we're doing that there's been some
comedians that have read for parts yeah
and they're not very good um and it's
and it's not just me like like
when it's done they're like okay anyways
and then you see here the other one but
that's what they expect from us is not
to be able to act
and when i did the first show in
december of 2001
uh um at the right before the cr right
before the christmas break i i read with
valentine valente was an actor i could
block him but i've done all kinds of
stuff and i was awful i could see it in
my partner's eyes like they were like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] oh really can't
act and then i went back and i said if i
told my manager
find me an acting coach and i had that
woman for like six years oh wow
but if i had if i had not if i had not
had the awareness to say man i can't
nobody asked me if i could act
if i hadn't done anything and just
thought oh [ __ ] i'll be all right that
all of this would not not have happened
because you we have to be able to
um act to understand the situation to
break down cole reading and stuff like
that and more of us would have an
opportunity to be something other than
just somebody that does stand up yeah
that would be like pigeon holed into
like one thing either right i feel like
right now i'm recognizing that i do want
to learn how to act a little bit more so
i can get uh better at those other
things you know um
yeah i mean even like in writing santa
like there's things that i feel like i
want to learn to write about more you
know in a way that's like
making my stuff different than what it
was before do you do characters in your
in your adwords just lines uh just just
like uh just uh yeah just lines um i
don't do any characters not yet i guess
but um we'll see any characters before
but i watched richard pryor live in long
beach for
maybe like a thousand
a thousand times and my grandmother
[ __ ] ate it
and she was walking
and i would be like hey grandma i'm
studying
and i mean
it just taught me so much man like and
there were no there was no youtube there
were no cell phones there was no
[ __ ]
uh anywhere you could go other than just
to see
a bhs yeah and then learn from that yeah
or maybe like see someone live too like
something upon it yeah yeah
how do you like ever decide like what
you want to like write about with like
your stand-up special and stuff like
that is there like ever like but i think
it's like you know since i've been doing
it for so long it's almost if you had a
program like you know
quicken yeah that that that it just
comes to you when you've been thinking
about it for your whole life
like they just they just pop in your
head gotcha you know
the amount of physicality that you throw
in there to go with to compliment the
joke
is it is important i don't know if you
learned that in acting school or that's
just you
but but there's to throw carry the joke
across there's a certain amount of
physicality yeah that goes in there with
it
i used to be a lot
more physical but
i'm not as spry as i
i tried to i tried to but you know uh uh
there's a there's a there's a rhythm to
the way i it's just almost back and
forth you see it like one two three one
two three
one two three and then standing around
the middle of it but it's like a one two
one two three one two three i might go
over here come back one two three yeah
one two three rhythm and you know chris
rock told me that you had that pace and
eddie murphy told our student you'll
tell them i like that
that one too that that kind of like
painting you know you're just painting
one two three let's feel nice one two
three like that you're not you know bam
and then waiting like you when you fill
in the gaps and all that like but i
think you know billy crystal said years
years ago that it's like boxing and it
is because you're in there you don't
know him you throw one out there you get
it you try you're trying to hook another
one connected to it yeah and then
almost like flying the plane like once
the plane gets in the air then what does
the pilot say we turn the fasten seat
belt sign off yeah and now you're just
you're just flying you're cruising i
think you're yeah right exactly
over here try this side can you go over
there and yeah yeah
it really does
um and uh uh
how long is your second business gonna
be it'll be an hour yeah an hour of
stand up and uh it's in particular it's
a little bit of a documentary too a
little bit of a documentary too so like
one of the elements i want to kind of
explore is you know people are always
like asking uh where how do you think of
your jokes and stuff like that so i kind
of want to take people the spots where
the idea for the joke has come from you
know like and also kind of exploring the
history of my neighborhood where it's
not specifically like here's the history
of glass oil park but it's more like
here's my history in relation to
glasweld park and talking about my
neighborhood the people that live in it
and everything in that one hour what
about the guys that you grew up with and
girls did you uh um we like still like a
lot of people still live in the same
neighborhood but some people have like
moved away and everything since some
people will hit me up and be like oh i
have been meaning to go to a show and
stuff like that and so um yeah it is
kind of cool to see like what people
become as they get older too yeah yeah
again you still have your nucleus of
friends that yeah i still have my best
friends uh from when i went to like uh
when i went to like elementary school
and everything my best friends louise
and daniel like we went to the same
school we still pursue stand-up together
it's real cool i'm happy that i i have
the ability to say that you know and
they're uh poquito nerdy like you yeah
they're a little bit married i think
that's a good question we all read comic
books yeah yeah political nerdy yeah
books
yeah i loved collecting comic books when
i was a kid like spider-man was like my
hero like that was my favorite comic
book to like read and collect
spider-man dc or marvel he's more of a
marvel
yeah which one is better let me ask
which one is better dc or marvel i like
marvel a lot more um i mean the movies
have been pretty like everyone's a hit
you know i've never been disappointed by
marvel movie like in the past like
dc like the wonder woman movie wasn't
good
[ __ ] i didn't watch anybody i didn't
watch that i haven't seen the movies
yeah and it wasn't in this they're like
blessing crips man
i wasn't in i wasn't into the comic
books and i haven't gotten seen any any
of the movies now now batman there's no
robin anymore huh
not in a thing not in these i don't know
what they're doing with him
robin's doing 15 to life
that'd be cool if he got out and the
game was closed you open up there's a
little folded thing with the r on it
yeah
i use rubber
but uh yeah yeah so marvel has all the
uh
iron man and i love the avengers and all
that sort of stuff yeah did you like any
of that stuff growing up i did i like
the i like spider-man yeah yeah and uh
remember the cartoons with the
j.j jameson you have to remember i'm
older i'm older than obviously you i'm
older than george so during those time
when all that was going on
number one
on the streets
you didn't
talk about that stuff then i went into
the army and i come back then i became a
cop i didn't have time for all any of
this [ __ ] so i didn't
you know i lost uh your your favorite
eddie van halen
i wouldn't know eddie van halen's song
today which is just not being
disrespectful
but i was listening to other stuff and
now in my car you turn around it's all
comedy stuff it's all i ever listened to
yeah uh so i i don't know a lot of these
now you talk to my grandson 22 years old
he's
all over marvel you know spiderman all
this [ __ ]
and my grandkids
how do you really feel
he puts it on on the tv
and
i just leave you know i just walked to
another room but did you ever go to
concerts when you were in high school or
anything like that no no i went to
concert you know one of the one of the
best
battle of the bands
buddy rich versus uh uh harry james
versus woody herman oh wow yeah so sam
and you went to that yeah yeah where was
that at that was at the carousel theater
in covina it was a new theater it's a
theater in the round up on the hill
right off the tennis i don't even think
it's there anymore oh wow man that's
yeah i went to go see uh buddy rich
before live
because i was i was a musician you know
i love music
and buddy rich i remember people were
talking when he first started playing
and he just said hey wait a minute stop
stop the [ __ ] he says hey you guys
pay to come and see me [ __ ] play
either shut the [ __ ] up and listen to me
play or get the [ __ ] out or i'll get the
[ __ ] out is that what he said yeah
yeah that's what i say
and he was just
and everybody started cheering for me
started again and it was a it was a
great cause so you saw buddy rich's
badass he's in whiplash he's listening
to one of the greatest drummers of all
time i think buddy rich gave freddie
prinze uh a drum set i think they were
on the tonight show freddy prince play a
little drums and they gave him a drum
set so those were my guys like freddie
prinz and i forget who he played for
either harry
or woody the next day in the paper it
said
uh one of them one i forget which one
won but only because he had buddy rich
playing for him yeah
a rich man it's like a cheat code yeah
yeah so it was awesome i remember seeing
johnny mathis when he was really [ __ ]
young yeah you know these guys so that's
that's what i was really amazing and i
didn't see
then i became a man of the 60s
and so all my money i remember go seeing
the temptations three nights in a row
that's amazing you know so i'd go see
where were they
i was asking no i i don't remember
you've been a real music fan uh when i
was when i was in high school i went to
actually a few uh rock concerts i i'd
seen van halen at the staples center i
think like around 2014 yeah yeah i went
my first concert which was a long time
for you huh yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
you realize it's like for for how old
were you then i was like 16 17 yeah
14 2014 he's like 16 years old
and yeah i saw i saw them and they were
great the first concert i went to was uh
roger waters the wall you know from
being floyd and everything i was just so
impressed by like the stage design and
seeing like the projections on on like
this whole stage that they built and i i
loved it like it felt like a whole like
experience being there you know so
you're a pink floyd fan of the music did
you go with your friends or i want my
dad to go see pink floyd for the first
time yeah and he was like trip out at
all
i probably had to stay up
yeah yeah yeah because you have a check
in the next day yeah i know um but yeah
he didn't do any of that sort of stuff
i've actually never gone high in my life
before
you you drank no never drank never never
smoked this dude has never drank or
gotten high straight out of cheese
[ __ ] that's funny i don't listen
to your money at all that's as good as
it gets for him yeah i think
if if i didn't drink or smoke i would
have thought my grandmother was just
mean not funny
hey how's your grandmother [ __ ] her i
don't think that's not entertaining at
all yeah
i had to i had a friend with me a young
kid
and his dad and i are we're cops
together and his he's young
uh
and he saw
the first thing he saw was the eddie van
halen guitar
and i thought this guy was going to piss
in his pants he thought it was the
greatest thing all in the room yes
he thought it was the greatest thing
going he said god damn you know and he
got all excited
and i said yeah because i know the
history because of you i know the
history behind it i said
don't you dare get within 10 feet of
that [ __ ]
it's a legendary guitar probably the
most iconic singing guitar there is see
with me i'd sit there and say god damn
it's a guitar i don't know
you always have a guitar with me sure
and uh
yeah always i'd bring one in here uh but
i used to but um
i don't have any musical abilities
i mean i love play play every day
but i just i maybe it's because i i
think i'm dyslexic or whatever the [ __ ]
it's just like i don't want to learn a
song all the way through i just learned
the beginning and then move over to
another one like i could never be in a
band
because i i would i just i don't know
man
stay focused for that exactly i think
you know you're gonna at least be like
uh check this out you play the first few
notes
oh this guy yeah yeah exactly yeah i
love that yeah but uh uh i just love you
know music was
big for me like rock music and that time
i mean i was in the 70s so
you were away yeah but you know first
man i saw was kiss and kiss and cheap
trick and then we saw i mean i [ __ ]
saw everybody man i made friends with
ted nugent that's awesome and
friends with van halen all the dudes are
van halen and sammy hagar and
the dudes that i call like santana and i
are like brothers man it's like that's
that's crazy
i liked like black sabbath and like yeah
like led zeppelin and stuff like that
like that was like the wheel being floyd
you know that was like the wheelhouse of
the stuff that i liked and gravitated
towards uh ozzy osbourne was one of the
concerts that i also saw with my parents
when i was like 16. that's nice it's
really fun yeah
those guys were well four tops
temptations midnighters
yeah
stevie salas just died
his other brother rudy died uh earlier
in the year you think when the light hit
him and he saw his brother at the in the
light you think they talked finally
after 30 years ago yeah yeah i think
they did and they started talking before
just before he died
before rudy died you know they were they
were you know
that that's one thing that i i mean i
don't know i guess it is in every
culture but
in our culture
we uh abandon people forever
you know we we don't talk to anybody and
then you think you're gonna live forever
and you know my grandmother had a
half-sister she didn't speak to i
haven't talked to my mother in a long
long time or you know have sisters that
nobody knows i have but you know in in
the act of being forgiving yeah is
ultimately the the you know the purest
act of of love could is to forgive
somebody but yeah you know it's so hard
though that was a tough one
it went for a long time how about that
just so sad i remember playing with them
in games when they were the salas
brothers
little they were
younger than i was and and they play
and of course i was friends with both of
them
through the years
it's not my family you know
yeah
so who have you seen what communities
have you seen or what actors have you
seen that that or anybody
that that you know you got nervous to
see um i i actually used to work as a
writer's assistant for will smith for a
little bit and like he would like walk
around in the workplace and everything
and that was someone i was always like
so impressed to see because he's such a
kind individual and like he'd always say
what's up and so i i really love that
about him i also saw jamie foxx once and
like i was like like oh man this is
crazy like that was a person where i
felt like very star-strucked person um
you know it's just i also like learning
when people are like really kind also
yeah it makes me feel good i'm like oh
yeah you can it makes me feel even
better yeah you can do all these amazing
things and not like have an ego about it
you know and that felt like very very
cool yeah jamie foxx i'd pay big bucks
just to go see because not only is he
talented as a comedian yeah he's an
awesome singer yeah yeah he can do it
all he could do it all and i mean
i just love
watching him yeah yeah he's he's great
very it's very like impressive yeah
so you're putting him up there on the
pedestal with the no with george lopez
but you know you see all those guys like
yeah he's
um arsenio like i've known arsenio for
you know met eddie murphy through
arsenio and that stuff and those guys
you know
i went to the arsenio hall show one time
with a
group of friends he said something that
was so funny and he said
i guess it was coming up on mother's day
or valentine's day any
and he's talking about hey come on guys
give it up take take your hair off the
bar of soap after you're done with the
shower
take your little hairs off
and let the wife use a remote once in a
while yeah
and
funny uh funny man when did you what was
your was that in the 80s [ __ ] had to be
in the 80s just still [ __ ] remote
there are remotes um they're so remote
yeah
what do you what are you let's let's
look at uh what do you what are you
watching right now on tv i do i love
that i love to watch cartoons uh that's
like one of my favorite things to watch
yeah what why'd you get it together i
didn't think that you would laugh at
that
i like to watch you watch your cartoons
eh i love it what do you like what do
you like i mean i i love to watch like
like
when i was a kid like hey arnold and
stuff like that was one of my favorite
things because
spongebob i still love to watch
spongebob i'm not gonna lie i like to
watch it's so funny there's so many
memes out there from like that same show
it's
i think it's evergreen really what about
the little bear underwater with the with
the with the astronaut suit
pretty funny
what's her name it's um sandy the
squirrel yeah it's a squirrel yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i grew up on spot but they but they
write that [ __ ] man so that it's
it's like meaning like it's entertaining
yeah the uh the barnacle bill and the
what's the other thing the two barnacle
boy and mermaid man stuff like that yeah
the batman and robin parody like in the
show yeah who was the old man ernest
borg it was
like the barnacle
barnacle boy yeah yeah and the other
that they're like batman and robin it's
some funny [ __ ] dude
i've never seen spongebob never more
spongebob only because until you just
said this yeah that's what my grandkids
used to watch but it's ernest burknight
he's a [ __ ] knife i think he won an
academy award
who else was who was kale's baby
mchale's name is her name ernie borgnine
and was it clancy thomas is that his
name was mr krabs yeah yeah yeah that's
brown clancy brown look at amazing man
like
tom kenny was a comedian i remember
seeing tom kenny do stand-up oh really
and then tom kennedy starts doing
[ __ ] voiceovers like that that
[ __ ] could buy a island and
nobody would know
he has a band also right now that he
does like shows with and then stuff like
that um i'd heard that he like had an
audition for snl didn't get that but he
got spongebob and i was like wow that's
that's amazing i would have never heard
him do spongebob if he got an snl that's
so crazy to think
who would even thought i mean
the you know the voice of
spongebob which i can't remember what it
is but
yeah yeah
that show was supposed to be educational
like that that was the intention then it
turned into like this whole different
thing it's like an empire yeah it's like
an empire yeah not even my grandkids who
grew up watching that [ __ ]
that's just crunchbob anymore
what other ones that that uh
okay so that's a good one yeah yeah yeah
um but you know listen yeah i love
watching cartoons when i was growing up
a lot of them were very racist i think
that's went into my fabric of who i am
yeah but but also
when you get older man like
there was i saw a little video last
night that that this old man
had lost his wife
right
and his kids got him out they rescued a
dog
to give him a dog and they had a like a
camera in the room yeah and that dog
when it's time to go to bed that dog's
running around the room and the man's
trying to catch a dog but eventually
they're both playing with each other and
he's jumping around he's in his 90s
and you think and that said you know
this it changed this guy's life yeah
like losing his his partner but then
having you know that the dog just shows
up but
that guy is just like he's he's
brighter than
sure than all of us when they go to bed
like that's a great and then he's
dancing around and the dog's chasing
them and they're doing this i mean it's
beautiful it's such a good feeling too
you know that we should never abandon
the things that
got us to where we are i don't think
yeah i don't think like that like
cartoons like i have never never used my
cartoons when i was growing up
was the roadrunner
yeah you know uh
with the yeah
[Music]
uh no that was not a jabber jabber job
was like uh not familiar with the other
one
or something like that oh yeah
that's what i would call
school
josiah
and on saturday mornings you had roy
rogers gene autry
uh sky king market sheriff john
lone ranger
sheriff john was on monday through
friday so was engineer bill money's
ready i mean they did they did things
were like they don't do those anymore do
they where were the guys pretending to
be
how can mr captain kangaroo
kangaroo mr green jeans
wow man you know the the uh documentary
of uh mr rogers
good mr roger was on forever but the
documentary of that dude is
pretty pretty emotional man like you
have you seen it no i wanted to you know
you cry you cried everyday come on
you're quiet when it just
the minute he started to put his sweater
on oh
i mean this guy was like about all of
the things in life that are good about
people
and people of different color not me but
him but people different color and in
the end man you just like you're just
like wow man that guy
so many times our heroes
have led us i don't think they can let
us down you know bill cosby
and things like that you know that that
you know you don't know what's really
going on but that guy was really about
what he was about and that's
that's [ __ ] different man eddie
murphy eddie murphy did a a great parody
on on him on saturday night live he did
oh probably yeah yeah yeah that was a
great parody on it yeah yeah yeah but
that stuff is uh
it's good man the um a lot of actors
like came out of like uh public access
television shows too like there was um
the electric company and i had morgan
freeman on that i remember yeah you
remember the electric company no
we did that didn't we show it in here no
it's anything uh it's like sesame street
um just i think on a different network
the electric company was
morgan freeman and they would do a thing
where
i think i said this somewhere before the
love of chair where the dude was sitting
in a chair
and they would talk about him on a
voiceover and he would move his hand
and that was it for the next tune in
next week
they had the whole thing
and the dude just he just moved his arm
and i mean that's how [ __ ] stupid we
were you
yeah anything you couldn't wait till
[ __ ] next man he moved no he didn't
what's he moving
then he'd fall out of the chair was the
big i mean crazy man like and and they
did it in a way where
you couldn't wait for the next
super sales great show super sales
yeah yeah yeah
i mean so i think we should not forget
you know and youtube has all that stuff
done
oh yeah i love it i i go i i i'm on
youtube an awful lot you know if you
believe in like in like energy you would
believe that if you went back to the
things that made you happy that
that they should still make you happy
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
i'm gonna do it deep down
tonight
the worst thing that some dude said to
me we're playing golf he said you're a
watch you know redtube i said what's
that you don't watch red tube
i said no dude what's that like porn i
said i watched porn my [ __ ] i'm married
man i went back watch red
[ __ ] driving
my number three button on my phone
catching up
that means it's the worst thing this is
the first season i learned something new
this first time i heard a red two don't
look yeah don't say kill search history
no serious don't look
everybody that's listening to this don't
if if it's not in your life
if you don't think that you'll become
anything about it don't don't look at it
keep the things in your life that make
you happy
not make you over there you know then
you and your wife you know you know this
dude told me that he was a musician
and in a in a pretty big band and he
said to me you just got married and i
said yes i think i've ever said this
publicly he goes can i give you some
advice and i said yeah he goes just make
sure your dick gets hard for home games
as much as it does for away games
oh
that's
couldn't remember the [ __ ] you said
about you don't know i'm laughing my ass
off the other day you said something
about people getting old married couples
and now sex is going about
you can't get wet i can't get
hard the same haircut and travel
go see jordan lopez microsoft
i said don't let your wife suck your
dick
you want your wife to put her mother on
something that pisses on for 70.
the same haircut
you know you see them too one time
when i first started to see couples with
the same haircut i was in the house and
lanai and these
these two people got off the course you
walked right into the bar and said how
did you guys play today and i was like
the [ __ ] lady
i thought they were [ __ ] dudes man
they go that's ted i have tits
oh my god
you didn't see that she had 10 cycles
they're [ __ ] up bigger than mine
it's always interesting seeing couples
all look exactly the same i always say
that at disneyland i always say that
disneyland is like you know people say
that they look like they're [ __ ] dogs
they do yeah they really do how do
[ __ ] people end up looking like
they're dogs i don't know my dad got a
skinny white one not me
how long have you had your dog uh you're
in february
and when you go home is happy to see you
oh yeah
you when he sees me coming he starts
whimpering
and he gets all excited start [ __ ]
running around and telling me that
you think dog's a man best friend go
lock your wife in the trunk of your car
for 10 minutes and lock your dog and
open the trunk and see who's happy to
see you
but i don't know why do you think wives
take a take uh you have a girlfriend i
do have a girlfriend yeah yeah uh we've
been together for like about five years
now where'd you meet her where'd you
meet her like
in a biotech
yeah yeah yeah exactly where would you
guys meet though uh we actually met at a
concert uh when we were in high school
through a mutual friend and then we
caught up again when she moved to l.a
oh very cool yeah yeah
what what i don't know
what i talked about spongebob now about
meeting my girlfriend
yeah but but but yeah so did she live
out here or no she lived in fontana then
she moved to l.a yeah you're a white
girl no no also latina yeah she's not on
meth she has all her teeth yeah she has
all of her teeth yeah
i think i call it like fun tucky or
something like that
yeah that's hilarious yeah when you
start to smoke chemicals you're like oh
we're getting close to fontana we're
gonna let you out
yeah exactly so so um
how is it to i mean i don't know man
because it's like you're talking to
somebody from another you know they land
here forever
so so what is it like now you guys don't
live together i have your own place my
girlfriend and i yeah we live together i
live with my grandparents at the moment
i'm taking care of them right now so we
live in the same space we have like our
own um spot and everybody have their
facilities
yeah we have like a pretty good
arrangement there is are any of them on
uh adult you know my grandmother would
would needed diapers
and but my grandma was very vain so she
would say protective garments
she would correct me yeah so
you know that's the house that she grew
up and i said well just go down there
and not and don't forget
to get the diapers and from the hallway
around the corner in the room that i
grew up in she'd go protect that garment
i mean she could [ __ ] hear diapers
from a mile away yeah
if you're at the car and go i said don't
forget grandma's protect them i mean
and you know it's funny man because as
they get older yeah
like i knew my grandmother was i mean
frail
and she was very vain and
but it's funny when i looked at her in
person
i still kind of in my head
maybe filled in the blanks of what i of
what might have been missing you know
when you see somebody you don't see them
as they are you see them as you think
they are yeah and then uh brian you know
came to my house one time and i said uh
let's take a picture with my grandmother
and i took a picture of my grandmother
and she looked she didn't have her teeth
in and she was probably meant like under
100 pounds
and if i looked at her
i wouldn't have seen her like that and
until i saw that picture i saw
what what she really looked like like in
my in my mind i filled her out in the
parts that she was missing sure again
you see the perspective afterwards
you're like oh man
like a picture is a picture but in my
head like you maybe you you know you you
recolor you fill in the missing parts
you know that's so true too yeah i mean
i feel like it happens a lot too like in
my space from like oh i i you take care
of them every day right i take care of
them every day yeah so i'm just i was
always i feel like when i was a kid i
was annoyed by like how overprotective
they were but then as i've gotten older
i'm like oh that's just how they are
because they care they don't want me to
be like what my parents were when they
were younger you know so like all comes
from like a place of love but they don't
know how to like put it in a delicate
way yeah they still they're still
married too right they're still married
yeah you've been married uh for like
over 40 years they always talk [ __ ] to
each other about being married like
we're married 46 years you don't even
take me outside you know stuff like that
yeah outside for a walk or anything like
that yeah my grandma just likes to talk
[ __ ] at this point in her age you know
she also thinks like everything bad that
happens on the news is happening
everywhere you know
um yeah the spanish news really has
rotted her brain in that regard what
does she have the spanish news has like
really like [ __ ] up her brand dude one
time you know james hahn uh uh when he
was running against viragosa um
uh did a commercial where a guy was
smoking crack that
you know he i guess i don't endorse
letting people out of jail so when i
went to my grandmother's house she said
did you see that
the guy
okay he smokes crack and i said who
smokes crack
the guy running for mayor virgos i said
yeah
i said grandma he's not smoking crack he
goes there's a commercial on tv that
says that he's smoking and and
she didn't vote for him because of the
commercial yeah that she said that in
the she believed it was in the
commercial and not like a willie horton
commercial
that he smoked that he smoked crack
and it was just a james han yeah
anti-beer or ghost bomb he won anyways
but i don't think he you know he allowed
sound when it won the second time it
does so much damage too like the way
that like they they consume like media
and everything like that like in that
same space of the of the new zealand
that they watch they watch this one
called alex tremo the extreme like
that's like the super crazy
one like they have like exorcisms and
everything on it you know wow what is
that alex alex demo it's like
it's it's one of those things it's on
like i think like at nine o'clock at
night like so that just before you sleep
you can have a nightmare like that's
basically what they make it and every
night they watch it yeah every night
what if you stood in front of the tv
they would be like get the [ __ ] out
they're like you see this is what
happens you know like they'll just keep
warning me um i i hate when they like do
like the things where they see like they
retain the guadalupe in something
because my grandma ends up staring at
stuff for too long trying to find like
that you're my toast
we come from a culture that believes
that a statue in mexico christ tears of
blood yeah i won't believe that you and
the girl from work are just friends
you just said that on channel five yeah
yeah and they all laughed and they all
they yeah they knew that yeah they knew
back in the station like to me like to
me
that
in my in you know in my
working of the culture yeah it that is
the one i would say what joke have you
written that defines what you think of
the culture i think is that they think
that
a statue either grows hair
cries tears or christ tears of blood or
moves but won't believe that you and the
girl from work
are just
you know they just mad [ __ ] i
remember there was a restaurant called
elgato on super great place they pulled
it down over there
elgato's on the command
they don't have any more elgatos and
i went with some people from work in
these open booths and then my [ __ ]
girlfriend shows up and she puts her
hand on the table like [ __ ] this is
where you are i was in the middle so i
figured that out
and she just drove around to to
restaurants until she found elgato at
the officer oh my god but i mean
crazy man like out of their minds i mean
it still happened so hard i think that
still happens yeah but
on social media you leave a bigger
footprint than you did when you were
true just you know hey you know parking
your car around the corner so nobody
could see it or put your hood my friend
man would go crazy dude he'd go to my
his girlfriend's house and put his hand
on her hood and he'd go okay we're good
i said what you mean because she's been
home because it's not hot i'm like it's
like that's how bad it got
to where he would we would drive by his
house turn the lights off roll up he'd
get out and go put his hands on the hood
of her car and then come back and say
okay one of my partners
uh we were and a
dear friend of mine he retired
and went in the pi business how come
your friends that you can't say name i
say friends name of mine well i can't i
can tell you yeah his name is gil parra
you know you he was my partner
he retired i was supposed to take over
his business you know hey i'm gonna run
a year when you're ready to go you can
have it
doing pi work
so
he did it and he used to tell people
women would come to him hey i want you
to check up on my husband because i
think he's cheating on me and he'd say
save your money you think he's cheating
on he is
before you even spend your money hey you
want proof i'll give you proof
but
i'm telling you if it's already that
point where you think he is
he is would you would you allow your
girlfriend to look to your phone i think
i would yeah wow yeah would you
i'm not seeing anyone but no
god a lot of boundaries
also yeah boundaries yeah i i would but
also i'm not gonna let this person do it
because of boundaries you know yeah but
but also you know i think now
it is what it do you guys have the same
interest and stuff like that like
um yeah i mean we have similar interests
and stuff we both like she drink or not
drink she drinks yeah yeah so she drinks
we like going to like art museums and
stuff like that flea markets
uh she yeah she'll like she has like a
vape and stuff like that
but i mean if you if you you know i'm
just gonna try i'm just gonna try to put
together she drinks she smokes a little
weed yeah we go to an art museum yeah of
course yeah have you ever seen a picasso
high
yeah i love it yeah but
i never took a girl to art museum
it has to be like something has to be
happening i think at the museum because
i can't just like stare what's going on
over there by the brits like the tupac
is there a tupac exhibit over there over
la live yeah they're having like a tupac
exhibit right now what's it what's in
there i think it just has like some of
his like poetry and like some other like
artifacts from his life for my hotel i
could see
down below wake me when i'm free it said
and then yeah i saw tupac in the uh
that's how old i am i saw tupac driving
in a two-door mercedes by himself with a
with his new rag and the thing is that
anyone you know
yeah that's tight do you go to museums
and stuff like that or you know what do
you like to do in like your free time in
europe i play golf yeah playing golf
since 1981
[Music]
i'm at home trying to learn
songs that i first started to play in
1977
and then i collect guitars and
you know i like music and yeah you know
when i took a big vacation went to
europe and they wanted to go my wife
wanted to go to the louvre did you go oh
no i didn't know and i told them
well some of our friends did and then i
i didn't
i said i told my wife i said hey
we've been married this long dear
i said we have museums we can go
anywhere we want to back now i do
never once asked me to go to a museum
but now you didn't go you didn't go into
the louvre no i didn't and i'm glad i
didn't
my friends it went they said it was
elbow to elbow [ __ ] they have the
venus wing bean they have the mona lisa
in there the mona lisa yeah six of my
friends went
only one of them got close enough to see
the mona lisa and they said gil it was
only this [ __ ] big overreach
no but it's still and and so
i could look at it in the magazine
that's
hey so you so you you don't you don't uh
you don't get a a sense of
accomplishment like standing
if you went to rome and standing in the
coliseum no or sitting in the vatican no
now now
i loved going through would you
what would i what if you went to europe
like and if you went to venice and did a
gondola or you went to rome and sat in
the vatican would it mean something to
you it would mean something to me
because i got to do something that most
people don't get to do and i think
that's a privilege right now i got to go
i had
a better time
going to see where the americans landed
normandy
that now that was touching him that was
important
on the other on the other side i don't
know if they landed there my wife
they still have those metal
yes those things that they couldn't get
through like those kind of things that
were put in the sand those crossings
that's awful my my wife on the other
hand
right after we left the vatican we got
back into the limo or whatever was
driving us around
she cried like a baby
and she just says thank you i can never
thank you enough
this
was all we're just seeing the battery
because she's a very
she did she go to the cat he comes under
they have the
other people buried the post no
no no but she was just so moved by it so
that made the whole trip worthwhile
that in and of itself it's but the rest
of the [ __ ] i can look at it on the
display so you went into the vatican yes
have you been to the vatican i've never
been to the vatican i've actually never
been out of the u.s
yeah you should oh if your girlfriend
loves art yeah
you go on the louvre or you go see uh
the david you know it's in florence the
moment i got to see uh uh notre dame
went to see uh
the do you mean notre dame cathedral of
notre dame
i i went to the uh with the
was it the eiffel tower yeah when i was
in front of the eiffel tower some guy
comes by and says hey
he says uh kill creole and i said yes he
says
he says you don't remember me
i'm a defense attorney
he says i want to get you into trial
and i'd say oh this is going to get up
guys he says hey don't worry you won
because it was really good that you saw
a guy in front of eiffel tower he
recognized me and he was with a guy that
was with a
deputy attorney from here
and so
met him right in front of you
i don't think so they they were just
maybe
i saw a guy that i shared an office with
uh when i was working for the sheriff is
that all in paris the louvres in paris
right the liberals yeah right there
there's another big ass cathedral and
you know me actually
bro
when i went to italy there was another
big cathedral
what's that one oh the spanish status
the basilica what's it the basilica yeah
yeah yeah florence where's the basilica
in uh that's in the vatican right it's
what no no no i went to london i went to
westminster abbey so now when you see
like uh uh where prince charles and uh
and diana got married is right there
you know um
and i mean there's da vinci's like just
in a church man like my wife was excited
going to see where kennedy got shot you
know we were right there took her there
through the whole thing
and it was it was a tough uh
that's
that was nice that's a tough one and and
uh with the x on the street it's not
that it's not that far
uh but i think there's you know
conspiracy i believe the conspiracy is
there they've been marked on the street
i've i've read so much on the bullet
trajectories and stuff because you know
i'm into this stuff and it's a tough one
even um
but were you
an officer when robert kennedy got shot
no
no because there's a i was in high
school when uh i remember the assembly
when they told us there's a there's a
woman that they saw in a polka dot dress
that there's a whole conspiracy behind
that shooting as well for rfk um
i didn't know that
was she wearing a monica lewinsky dress
i don't think there was any crema on it
but you know everything is not i mean
everything's not
as it seems you know in that time i mean
the cia and
probably just stopped talking about it
we'll be back at your house yeah the
secret service is coming back
i think i'm too strong i don't think i
got one more but yeah so those are the
things that um
um
interest you like you know museums and i
think that's yeah yeah i like just being
able to see other things because i also
kind of like shapes the things that i
want to talk about and the things that i
want to like pursue when when creating
things you know um
were you an artist did you draw at all
or anything i wish i could draw i mean
whenever i would like send letters like
my my uncle or my dad in prison they'd
like come back and they'd have like
those like crazy elaborate drawings
yeah and i always be like man like i
wish i could draw like this yeah but you
know the [ __ ] totals man
like you look at mr cartoon yeah um when
mr cartoon was in junior high they told
him that he was weird because he could
draw like they made him feel inferior
and he didn't draw for like four years
but also like those children they're
they're talented they're great artists
talented
painters and and
and yeah yeah like i i'd see like those
black books sometimes kids will tell you
like black books at school and you'd
open it up and you'd see them like
practicing their tags and stuff like
that and you'd be like this is really
good you should share this with other
people a good buddy of mine ray who's
never been to the joint you think that
he's been to the joint for years he does
a lot of stuff with pencil beautiful
stuff
yeah beautiful stuff on
so there was a guy that uh
that
you know i go to san francisco and give
toys and that and there was a girl that
her grandfather she said i think you
know my grandfather and she said the
name and i said yeah i do
and i said what is he what is he doing
now and he he murdered somebody
and he is doing life in san quentin but
this kid was like you see me he was
he was an artist father was an architect
and he was an artist
and he was getting bullied and he
and he
killed somebody that was bullying him
and he went to he went away but i mean
this dude is like the least person like
when she told me that i couldn't believe
it but then i could believe it that
that guy
would do something like that and just
had him satisfied yeah no he said not
not
that one bit sorry he did it
man i mean
and he used to do like we're in a night
like in the 60s he would draw
the apollo rocket with a pencil like his
father you could just be so good at it
man
like so good at it and the way that he's
to hold a pencil just kind of make these
little marks like like this guy that did
this
there's so much technique in that too
like the shadows and everything like
it's amazing rudy moreno over there yeah
so we got or 135 so we got a little bit
more time or we can wrap her up what
time we started at 12
you'd have thought i came in at two
o'clock in the afternoon the um
are you uh i know we were ready to
hammer you so so uh what what i you know
what idea do you have
for the future of your career oh yeah i
feel like you believe in manifest
destiny yeah
uh
well i like manifesting and everything
like that yeah yeah like
the expansion and the expansion of the
west yeah yeah yeah really latino
manifest destiny
you know man i'm going to say that
and when i did the white crime special
in 2005 and when the dvd came out i sat
and did a half hour uh special of just
me being interviewed and everything i
said in the half hour came true
that's awesome it's amazing they asked
me what i wanted to do and i mean
everything that i've wanted to do
i've done but i think it's manifest
destiny um i i would love to be able to
have a career where i can just like tour
and things like that you know i would
like to be able to have um specials and
albums that like really signify
different chapters of my life and things
like that so i have like a good library
where people can see like oh this is
like the beginning this is where like
things have changed and stuff like that
because i feel like that would really
demonstrate my growth as an artist and
that's something i always want to be
able to do is to grow and get better and
not just like have only one good thing
you know um
if we're like talking like like large
scale and everything you know i'd love
to uh buy back part of the block you
know i'd love to be able to like buy
back some of the stuff that's changed in
my neighborhood and create like an art
center or something where people can
really benefit and share their talents
as well you know there's this really
awesome thing that i've heard where you
know
you could start your phone you could
start a foundation and do that yeah i
could yeah there's this thing that i
always think of where it's like talent
is spread evenly throughout the world
opportunity is not and i think of that
so much and i feel like that would be
such a great thing to to manifest a
place where people can create uh you
know
this is like dreaming big but i would
love to like be in consideration for
like a grammy or something at some point
with like my work and and yeah
um just creating content and
being as good as i can be yeah
yeah as long as he's not on there and
all year yeah
i never lost to a comedian
i was nominated three times i didn't win
i lost to weird al i lost a flight of
the concourse and i lost stephen colbert
i never lost to a comedian
damn dude
what is stephen colbert considered i
know his show but what has he considered
i did an hour and a half live special in
san antonio in front of almost 16 000
people and he did a half hour special
for comedy central uh for christmas
isn't he like a character yeah oh i
remember that yeah yeah yeah and that
was not a standard like comedy special
that was insane man
the first year i was at pebble beach
playing golf they said you're gonna go
back and i said i don't know and then
somebody said that weirdo always wins i
said i'm not going and then when i was
in
america's mexican i didn't win and then
i didn't go to the ceremony and then
nine
i went there and they had us all on tv
and i [ __ ] lost just like that what
what did it feel like for you to be
nominated like what did that you know um
you know
i think you know for writing on
those little notebooks or writing on gas
company or envelopes from you know from
bills yeah i would say that it's an
honor to be to be nominated three times
and and now when i won an emmy for a
voiceover that i did for the dodgers
like in l.a that's awesome and on the
same
in in 18 30 years after my grandfather
died and and that was a year that my
grandfather said
in spring training the dodgers were
going to win and they weren't very good
and i said [ __ ] and he died opening
day and then they won and i got an emmy
for
that world series which means almost
like if it was sent to me yeah you know
that's amazing yeah
yeah i remember when i was in houston
because you had to wait till the next
morning because of the news there wasn't
you know all that news we have now and i
was in the apartment by myself and i was
i was crying because they won and i was
like man i was telling that they won you
know and then 30 years later yeah i do
this voice over for me and sam jackson
and sam it's only emmy sam jackson's
ever won wow and he's like [ __ ] i you
know and then i have it at the house i
look at it every day my dad was such a
dodger fan
he was he was he's such a fan that he
would leave in the seventh inning if
they were losing one there's like my
grandfather really [ __ ] they're gonna
lose let's go he was he had at that time
transistor radios all over the house
three in his in his truck
one time he got he got in trouble with
my mom because she thought he had an
earache he had the wire running up there
at a rosario at a road
sitting there like this listening
he he was suffering and
died from cancer
march 17th saint patrick's day and my
dad always said they said hey mexican
get away under this yeah i'm not mexican
smoked irish just a little well done
and he died on st patrick's day so
i'm coming up dead
how are you doing today
i said i'm not doing too good
he said but it doesn't make any
difference he's ain't no reason the
dodger was having a bad spring training
he says dodgers are going to come
continue playing the way they are right
now because they ain't no reason to
continue living
he's just
they got to turn around wow and he was a
he was a big time dodger fan i think
they you know my grandfather i think
they might show i don't think they're i
don't think anybody's like this anymore
but they love those teams so much yeah
and they show more lipsticks to their
family like my grandfather didn't go to
my [ __ ] high school graduation and he
was listening to [ __ ] dodgers man
in my family because of my dad
you know back then they used to have
these nylon jackets a big dodger jacket
so we didn't have a bunch of money so
got one for my mom got one for my dad
and then everybody's birthday throughout
the year everybody chip in their money
and buy
their sister their man until everybody
in the family had the blue jackets
that's cool also together
yeah
that's a big deal it was
there's all love for sports teams you
know because we
what are your teams uh lakers dodgers uh
dallas cowboys uh biotech company in
westminster
yeah yeah
those are like the teams that we grew up
with and stuff like that are you lakers
or clippers uh lakers yeah yeah yeah
how could anybody be a clipper
it's weird
it's weird to like see i saw someone's
bumper sticker coming over here they're
clippers dodgers and then um
yeah it was like you're you know if you
go clippers dodger it's almost like
you're in vegas and you're like oh i got
a seven seven and a oh [ __ ] cherry
like
you can't beat you can't be it shocks me
how many mexicans are follow the lakers
the way they do
you don't see too many tall i mean none
of them they're all so short they don't
play they don't play basketball yeah and
i never got into the game the best part
of basketball is the last two minutes of
the game you know
i would say that you know growing up
watching
you know will chamberlain and kareem and
everybody that yeah
it's not that i don't like the lakers
now it's that when you
manufacture a team instead of a team
just happening
that you end up with seasons like this
where you know i love anthony david i
love those guys are great but it's like
we manufactured a team they didn't win
when they had carl malone and gary
payton and yep you know those guys
but
those years with kobe and tan you know
friend of the family and things like
that like
i i don't think i'll ever walk into
the crypto.com arena ever again in my
life yeah i don't see i don't see myself
walking i i was a i used to love him
back then i mean i wasn't basketball it
never was a big basketball but guys like
the guys elgin baylor yes wilt
chamberlain yeah jerry west jerry west
the best these guys were
the jerry west is the nicest person how
he built i mean he got he got us kobe
but then he's been the general manager
of other teams when he should have been
our guy forever almost you know yep and
then dr bus
there's that whole mini series starting
you know that's going to be on hbo but
yeah i knew him and then you know i went
to the games when when uh all that was
happening and that's the kind of owner
i would be if i owned
a final sports team yeah you all right
i'm good
you get your results from your cat
scandal that's it and said go back to
the free clinic
yeah how was it beautiful huh hey man
yeah it's awesome to meet you dude i
wish you the best on your career and uh
you know a pleasure thank you great
really well always do what makes you
happy brother keep writing and keep
banging and i look forward to seeing
your special i appreciate you both
thanks for having me on and uh please
tell the people where where to follow
you where to find your stuff
nerdy yeah yeah yeah the be great uh
handle um uh you can follow me on ig and
tic toc vince caldera um that's
v-i-n-c-e-c-a-l-d-r-a i'm sure it'll be
like in the bio and stuff oh yeah um
my special will be at the bob baker
marionette theater uh may 10th the may
12th 7 pm at 9 00 pm each day
awesome thank you i'm going to be in
town but i would go if i was there
i was in town yeah i would go
i'll send you i'll send you the video
yeah yeah get you on the next one yeah
yeah exactly uh gil will be there and
[ __ ] ruin the whole day
you don't know if he's laughing because
you're bombing or you're laughing
you know there was there's always people
that laugh that loud and shows you know
and you would be like hey go over there
and tell that lady you know not to be
laughing so long
and then this guy would go over and go
hey joe lopez tell me tell your mate
shut the [ __ ] up i can't say that
oh that happened to me in arizona where
i asked the guy to tell the lady to just
you know it was louie anderson i went to
see him i lectured back in the fbi
academy
in uh quantico and i went to he was in
virginia he was in virginia i went to
see him he's great and so i went back
there to see him
and had front row seats
and at the end of the show he comes up
to the table he says god damn thank you
a lot man i could hear you laughing and
then he found out he says hey you know
too bad you're not from around here so
i'm going to be back here next week i
said no no i'm sorry i'm going to be
back in l.a because i'm going to be in
la next month he says come on out seats
are on me
yeah that's so cool
let me ask you a question yes sir how
does bob saget hit his head that bad and
go to sleep is that you ever seen
anything like that well yeah it it's not
impossible that's why they tell you
whenever you get hit in the head you
have a concussion don't let them go to
sleep but they said it was like a like a
serious
well what would cause that if you hit
your head it uh fallen in the bathroom
well that they were you'd have to look
it's a serious fracture though right
well i didn't see the fracture i didn't
pay attention to the autopsy report they
have real people looking at that thing
you hit it
back at the base of the skull down at
the bottom of it okay that's where
everything comes up the stem comes up
into the brain
so
you hit it and once you get in the brain
your brain is in a sack of water like in
a fluid so you get hit back here they
they have something that's called cool
and contracou so you hit it back here
and it'll bruise on the front
because it shakes back and forth so who
knows how much it takes how long it
takes whether it's fracture or not
because you can fracture your skull and
not die
yeah so you just
write
they're doctors i'm not wow man but they
said and it's tragic
but there was nothing in him so he's
good and i gotta believe that's the
thing to say you know like like uh
you know we've been in hotel rooms
forever if you sure you know almost fall
or you i've fallen before in rooms that
you you know you would naturally if
you're in your room you're going to go
to sleep you're by yourself of course
you're going to go to sleep which is
what's important that's a natural thing
to do i i can remember
as much as i laugh
i had been
imbibing all night long i was in reno
and i was in the shower stepped out of
the shower and when i stepped out of the
shower was a tub with an enclosure i
stepped out the left foot hit the floor
and slid
and i started to go down and i tried to
grab the sliding door ripped the [ __ ]
out of my arm here i went down
hit hit the floor and as soon as i hit
the floor nobody else was in the room
the first thing i did was just go safe
and i started laughing and i started
laughing to myself
then i got myself up so that's it's it's
dangerous man that's i think it's you
know i know we you know you know and
then you you hear what happened he was
we're in here and it's just
it was just
last month couple of months ago when you
were doing your thing in here with i
don't know that's a trip that's crazy
you know that that's what it what it was
like late november wasn't something like
that yeah just recently wow
all right
okay everybody thank you thank you thank
you
you